so they're all staying getting up and  i'd say joe what about me  you looked around and he goes like this  everybody sat down like he was gone  everybody sat down he's what are we  going to do for my boy here they say  we're going to give him a part i said no  no no no i said either i play michael's  sonny or call him  so they said well this is a news to a  lot of people in your audience they said  we already cast sonny  it's carmine karidi he's a broadway play  man from la mancha big guy  and james khan is playing michael i said  who's playing carl there's a number i  saw i'm playing caller they looked at  each other and joe says he's playing  carlo  that was it so then they played another  game on me they have your age and call i  said i got no agent you don't have an  agent  no he says are you in the union i said  no  i said don't worry about it i did my  homework this is a taf hartley's day  right to work state you give me the  letter i'll go join the union now